we're talking about marvel's avengers
beta we're talking about sony increasing
ps5 production and we're talking about
assassin's creed
bringing back social stealth i'm current
davina this is safe state game spots
big old news show for wednesday july
15th welcome
[Music]
that marvel's avengers game is getting a
beta and it's starting next month
in august but with a very minor caveat
and that is getting staggered across
platforms
folks who pre-ordered the game on the
ps4 will get it on august 7th
then other ps4 players and people who
pre-ordered it on xbox one and pc
will get it on august 14th but then
finally on august 21st
it'll be available to all xbox and pc
players and to hold you over until then
the next avengers war table stream
will be on july 29th at 10 am pt and
we'll be giving some extra detail on
what to expect from the beta the game's
creative director told ign that the beta
will include campaign missions
co-op character progression and
exploration in war zone and drop zone
saying it is quote meaty the game's
going to be coming out for ps4 xbox one
and pc on september 4th
with the ps5 and xbox series x ones to
follow
sometime so initially it was reported
that the ps5 was going to launch with
less units than the ps4 and given our
current coronavirus pandemic that makes
sense
however not even kovan 19 is going to
stand in the way of sony making its
magical virtual escapism box
according to a new report from nikkei
asian review the ps5 production orders
have increased from 6 million
to 9 million now the report doesn't say
when they'll be produced it also says
that
number can change based on market demand
separately bloomberg reports that sony
wants to produce 10 million units by the
end of 2020.
if this all pans out that means getting
one this holiday when it launches
seems feasible that is if you can afford
it because we don't know how much it's
going to be it could be expensive
it may not be or it could just be a cake
who knows
the assassin's creed games were founded
on one very basic principle
pretending you look sweet while you
discreetly disappear into a crowd it's a
piece of its identity that has since
faded from the franchise but it's coming
back according to valhalla's level
designer social stealth is coming back
saying quote we do have this mechanic of
disguise where you can put your hood on
and in different locations where you
want to blend in more get less detected
you can put it on and it's a mechanic
you can use to social stealth between
crowds we're also bringing back the
social stealth of the monks
walking around you can blend in with
them so rest assured knowing that you
can go back to looking all
moody and ominous with your hood up and
not conspicuous at all
when assassin's creed valhalla comes out
on november 17th for ps4
xbox one and pc with the eventual launch
on ps5
and xbox series x okay
that's it for news however we still have
one more thing to talk about and that is
that gamespot has launched
its very own merch store we're selling
t-shirts we're selling this poster and
a skateboard till the end of august all
these proceeds are going to be split up
between
black lives matter and coven 19 relief
so
there'll be a link to that in the
description below there's also a hoodie
there's also a face mask
it's exciting i'm excited about it you
should
too yeah okay all right
that's it for today of course you can
find out about everything i just talked
about
and more by going to gamespot.com once
again
i'm curtain davina it's been a pleasure
telling you news talking to you hope
you're well
wash your hands tell someone you love
them
yeah be cool be nice all right see you
[Music]
later
[Music]
you